ich hab einfach geträumt dass ich
irgendwie so eine geile rolle von hinten
gepusht habe und mich dabei die ganze
zeit an gefeiert hat
hey leute jetzt willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge war falsch mit den beiden
[ __ ] sie am start wo es lose hey jungs
was du nicht ich schwöre dass keine
kollegen
wieso bin ich der wieso bin ich
überlebensmodus ihr weg sie wollten nur
boxen mixers ja alte fängt an jörg ehmer
neu fängt an wir machen eine andere
reihenfolge immer wieder eine geschichte
und zwar folgendermaßen ich bin kann ich
ihn schreien ich versteh ich nicht
falsch ich bin ich habe kollegen nach
hause gebracht
auf der straße von schwester gepumpt ab
jetzt ist eine lüge
überlauf der sprachwahl geldscheine
youtube und wie man nicht natürlich
kennt wie er mich einsetzt bin ich eben
amtlich ihnen voll zu der polizei
gegangen auch so habe dieses
portemonnaie abgegeben und hat 150 euro
bekommen das war die geschichte
ich da falsch was falsch
was ist mit deinem kopf das ist einfach
wahr es ist einfach wahr
ich dachte weil das ist so weil die
story so verdammt noch mal scheiße ist
verhüllt lasse ich aber das ist falsch
bis wir uns verarschen hässlich ist
sowieso war
richtig scheiße so richtig
schweißgebadet und kenne das aber den
wie einschläft und dann aufwacht und das
einfach ich denke ich aber kompakt zu
stehen aber weiter versuchen übertrieb
es ein alptraum
ich habe etwas geträumt dass ich bin wie
so eine geile alles gepasst hat
dabei die ganze zeit an gefeiert ich
hab' ich lache ich würde sagen das ist
natürlich dass meine damen und herren
okay leute also also das war in der
grundschule der dritten klasse und bei
solchen spielen ist ja immerhin zwischen
lehne und zwischen der sitzfläche ein
kleines loch und immer als wir im
unterricht also langweilig war habe ich
mich irgendwie immer durch dieses loch
so gezwungen
und irgendwann habe ich durch dieses
loch nicht mehr durchgebracht und wir
dann darin steckengeblieben
wir müssen halt alle nicht was sie da
tun solltet dann ist halt unsere
klassenlehrerin zu der lehrerin im
nachbarraum gegangen und die haben dann
gemeinsam versucht mich da raus zu holen
weil ich da halt echt fett drin steckte
das ist so wie mit zum rings um den
kriegst du drauf kriegst du den gut aber
abkriegen das ist das komische
und ja unsere klassenlehrerin hat er
meine füße genommen die andere lehrerin
in stunden der namen die mich gezogen
aber die haben das nicht hinbekommen
und schließlich musste der hausmeister
mit einem akkubohrer kommen mich
befreien
nein das wäre nicht so story bleib beim
thema die story ist einfach falsch weil
das um affig ist ich nehme mir immer
eine story von den usern und eine story
von mir deswegen nehme ich jetzt auch
nicht nur geschichte von mir wusste
den anderen kollegen feiern mit kollegen
feiern
schöner ball aus kurzer karte alles
schön und gut gemeint alles auf mich für
dich so viel wie ihr wollt
das war halt dann im endeffekt eine
schlechte entscheidung von ihm und von
uns das für ihn am steuer wurde und für
uns zur besinnungslosigkeit geführt hat
also trotz
wir mittendrin wenn sich die lachen und
am ende ist es einfach immer so ein
trauriges ende aber einfach keine fehler
machen will
ich weiß nicht ist das falsche lässt das
war ich dachte es ist ich sage es ist
also es wird jetzt ein bisschen eklig
also wir kommen jetzt zum ekligen teil
dieses formats und ihre hunde oder
katzen würmer haben
wie kann man junge mir ist gerade echt
kalt den rücken runtergelaufen 7 oder so
keine ahnung stichwahl fahrschule und
oder so
die jugendeinrichtung verletzt am arsch
kommen
das hat mich gejuckt und ich wusste mir
nicht anders zu helfen
damals als wir einen bleistift in den
arsch in der nacht zu stecken damit
wieder nicht raus klettern können
ich sage das war das ist wahr das ist
wahr
falls du bist zu jung gewesen
jetzt entscheidet es sich und was du
deine story allerdings mit würmern zu
tun aber ich war bei uns in der küche
und die kennt das ja wort sprachnotizen
so gedrückt halten und dann kann man
seine sprach mit aufnehmen mehr kennen
wir nicht was das alter nicht mal deine
sache schon wieder zehn meter von seinem
pc
naja jungs ebenfalls in der kritik
und ich hab halt diese spanne dienst
aufgenommen für eine freundin von mir
wissen wollte was machst du gerade und
ich so ja ich bin da am kochen und hat
all diesen ich hab mir halt so ein
backfisch gemacht und hab dann gedacht
so ja komm ich mache jetzt das erste mal
so wirklich super vier um die pfanne
drumrum damit dass nicht alles so voll
sprit tja das papier lag aber zu nah an
der herdplatte das papier hat dann
angefangen zu brennen und ich habe
während der sprach notiz gesagt ja ich
mache mir etwas sorgen gottes brennt auf
einmal alles um mein gott oh mein gott
oh mein gott und dann stellt das ich
dann wirklich das handy weg gelegt habe
habe ich weiter aufgenommen habe
vergeblich versucht mit einer hand das
alles wieder zu löschen weil ich eben in
dem moment war ich zu jung dafür oder
irgendwie spanisch irgendwie meiner hand
von dem handy runterzunehmen und
letztendlich hat es dazu geführt dass
geführt dass quasi die komplette
herdplatte marsch war alles hat mehr
oder weniger angefangen zu brennen also
die komplette zeitung
ich sage eine lüge ich hab sogar noch
die whatsapp sprachen und diese schickt
schickt ihr euch gleich wieder spielen
könnte sich auch abspielen
ja ich weiß nicht ob ich da etwas gesagt
hat wenn ich privat ist dann steigt er
braucht
gerade egal
ihr müsst es unterhalten dass das nicht
geht alter
da da da da da da okay okay ich mache
aufgenommen es war früh am morgen ist
weihnachten oder so am wochenende hatte
auch spaghetti offen also nicht dass das
erste weil ich legt er jetzt mal im zu
ersten mal in meinem leben so papier
darum damit sie damit das nicht so
fertig wird alles habe ich jetzt einfach
aufgenommen ich das reicht nicht einfach
weiter auf und brennt alles aber ich
habe einfach mal mit dem pfannenwender
drauf
verloren dafür dass sie die werte wer
darf sich ein punkt geben
mal hat es schon gegeben hast du schon
ich habe einen punkt ist ein punkt beim
start über unseren baum steht eigentlich
über unseren beiden sonnen punkt und bei
manuel nicht also in manuels name steht
da nicht fix das eben so
das ist ich schaffe es die luca was was
nein na ja ich würde sagen es euch
gefallen daumen hoch erlassen und dann
würde ich sagen nächsten mal wieder